>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Jane McAuliffe: Good evening.
How nice to see everyone here
despite our subway issues
in the district today.
I'm Jane McAuliffe.
I'm the Director of National
and International Outreach here
at the Library of Congress.
National and International
Outreach, or NIO as we call it
because we give acronyms
to absolutely everything
in the Library of
Congress, is a new division
of the library dedicated
to making the library
and its resources
ever more available
to the American people.
And an important part of NIO
is the Center for the Book,
whose director we have
with us tonight, John Cole.
The Center for the Book is
responsible for a number
of things, but especially some
major programs for the library,
such as the National Book
Festival, which is now
in its 16th year, and I
hope all of you will be
with us next September 24th
for this annual celebration
of our greatest authors,
poets, and illustrators.
The Center for the Book also
prepares the librarian's
selection of the
U.S. Poet Laureate,
a position currently held
by one Felipe Herrera.
And Mr. Herrera's final event as
Poet Laureate this year will be
on April 13th in the
Coolidge Auditorium.
And again, we hope many of
you will be able to join us.
And finally, the Center for the
Book has spearheaded the Library
of Congress Literacy
Awards program.
Through the generosity
of David Rubenstein,
the library has been able to
recognize and to make awards
to literacy organizations, both
in this country and overseas.
And the Literacy Awards brings
us to this evening's program
in its focus on how
literacy affects our health
and well-being.
Being able to read is essential
to our ability to obtain,
to process, and to understand
basic health information
and services.
If we cannot read, we can't
get the instruction necessary
to make informed
decisions about medical care
and after lifestyle adjustments.
And that brings us to our
symposium's cofounder,
the Nemours Foundation, which
is an integrated children's
health system.
It has hospitals in the
Delaware Valley and in Florida
and operates 45 primary,
specialty,
and urgent care clinics.
Nemours is responsible for
the website KidsHealth,
the most visited internet site
for information about health,
behavior, and development
for children right
through the teen
years, KidsHealth.
And it's become a very prominent
voice for children's health care
under the leadership
of its president
and CEO, Dr. David Bailey.
Dr. David Bailey, a pediatric
gastroenterologist, has been CEO
of Nemours for ten years.
He took his undergraduate degree
at West Virginia University
majoring, not unexpectedly,
in biology and ended
his MD at Penn State.
His residency program took
him here to Washington, DC,
where he was at Walter Reed
Army Medical Center and then
to service in the
Army Medical Corps
in Alabama, Florida, and Hawaii.
After leaving the military, Dr.
Bailey established the Division
of Pediatric Gastroenterology
at the Arnold Palmer Hospital
for Children in Orlando,
and he also did an MBA
at the University of Florida.
So he is the perfect
person, I think,
to bring to us some real
information around the topic
of literacy and health.
Please welcome Dr. David Bailey.
[ Applause ]
>> David J. Bailey: Thank
you very much, Jane,
for that very kind introduction.
I just wish my kids
could have heard it.
You know, I also want to welcome
all of you to this symposium,
which explores the
critical linkage
between literacy and health.
It seems fitting that this event
is held here at the Library
of Congress, which is one of the
world's foremost repositories
of knowledge and
accumulated wisdom.
We have a full day
of speakers tomorrow,
and I think you'll find
them both illuminating
and thought provoking.
Before I begin, I want
to take this opportunity
to recognize the
foresight and generosity
of David M. Rubenstein,
founder of the Library
of Congress Literacy Awards.
This symposium exploring the
connections between literacy
and health is made possible
through his generous gift
to the Library of Congress
and reflects his keen interest
in drawing public attention
to the importance of literacy
in all segments of society.
Although his schedule would not
allow him to be with us tonight
or tomorrow, I'm sure
he would be very pleased
with our commitment to
learn from each other
and to engage others in
this very important work
going forward.
Now, tonight, I would
like to tell a story
that I hope will connect us in a
very real way to why we're here.
This is a story of a boy,
the eldest of three children,
who grew up in Wyco, a southern
West Virginia coal-mining holler
-- not hollow; that's
holler in West Virginia --
that was [inaudible] of a narrow
valley, where the railroad track
and the dirt road roughly
paralleled the creek running
out of the mountains.
His father had dropped
out of the eighth grade
to support his own mother
and his six siblings.
The boy's mother was
18 when he was born,
and she did have a
high-school diploma.
In that coal-mining community,
practically every male
over the age of 16
worked in the coal mines.
Coal dust was constant.
It was on everything
and everybody.
Families lived paycheck
to paycheck.
And after every paycheck,
drinking was the major
recreational activity
for several days.
Practically all goods
for daily living came
from the company
store, which was owned,
sure enough, by the
coal company.
At one time or another,
almost everyone received
what were known
as government commodities,
usually cheese and
peanut butter.
Poverty was pervasive,
but, as there was nothing
to compare it to, it was just
life for the residents of Wyco.
At the pleading of his
mother, the boy was accepted
on a trial basis into the
first grade at the age of five.
He was bored because all of his
playmates were then in school.
He joined the other
five students, all male,
who comprised the entire
first-grade school.
The school had two rooms with
three grades in each room,
each grade composed
of one row of desks.
To the casual observer,
the boy's family was
indistinguishable
from any other in Wyco.
However, there were three
very important differences:
his father did not drink, his
mother had a high-school diploma
and loved to read,
primarily romance novels,
and both parents placed a
high importance on education.
Unlike all of his friends,
there were reading materials
appropriate for age in his home.
In fact, the only time he ever
saw books or magazines outside
of his home was at school.
His family once fell prey
to a door-to-door salesman
and bought a full set of
Encyclopedia Britannica.
Remember this was a
long time before Google.
These encyclopedias
became a prized possession
and were proudly
displayed in the front room.
For Christmas, just
before his eighth birthday,
the boy received a children's
book about Edward Jenner,
the 18th-century
British physician
who pioneered smallpox
vaccination.
This book ignited his desire
to pursue a medical career.
At age 16, he entered
college, the first person
from both his extended family
and from Wyco to do so.
He went on to medical
school at age 19
and stands before
you this evening.
I am that boy.
What happened to the other five
boys who made up the first class
in Wyco, West Virginia?
Tom graduated from high
school, worked in the mines,
and died of coal miners' black
lung about ten years ago.
Bill dropped out of
school, worked a while
in the coal mines, and
then became a hermit
in the hills around Wyco.
Mark dropped out of school
and was in and out of prison,
largely for theft-related
offenses.
Jim graduated from high school
but was severely injured
in a coal-mining
accident and lives
on Social Security disability.
And I've lost track
of my fifth classmate.
Based on empirical data, it's
now widely accepted that access
to printed materials is the
critical variable affecting
reading acquisition.
The complete lack of available
reading materials almost assured
that the five of the six
boys would not be reading
at grade level when they
reached the fourth grade.
That alone vastly increased
the likelihood that one of them
or many of them would drop out
of high school, which, in turn,
increased the likelihood
of unemployment by over 70%
when compared to
high-school graduates.
In retrospect, Mark and Bill's
lives, the ones who dropped out,
were sadly both a statistical
and a cultural norm.
My other two friends
hardly fared better.
Jim's accident and Tom's
premature death cannot be
surprises given the
difficult environment
in which they lived and worked.
People who are illiterate
or poor --
and they are very
closely linked --
are more likely to work
under hazardous conditions
or be exposed to
environmental toxins.
Most of you here
could have predicted
in general terms what would
have happened to those boys
in the first-grade class.
Unfortunately, more than 50
years later, in countless places
but with different faces, this
story is still playing out.
It's like a perverse
real-life version
of the movie Groundhog Day,
in which the same day gets
repeated over, and over,
and over until the
protagonist gets it right.
What does this story have to
do with literacy and health?
Everything.
Literacy dramatically affects
the outcomes in medical care.
However, literacy may be even
more impactful in those areas
that are now recognized as
having a much larger role
in shaping the health
of populations
than medical care alone.
A large and compelling body
of evidence accumulated
over the past 25 years
leaves little room for doubt
about the powerful role of
social factors in health.
The phrase "social determinants
of health" has been coined
to reflect this, and is
defined as the conditions
in which people are born,
grow, live, work, and age,
and includes the fundamental
drivers of those conditions.
These social determinants
have been categorized
into four separate dimensions:
social circumstances, behaviors,
the environment, and genetics.
Education, poverty, and housing
powerfully influence health.
For instance, for the
population as a whole,
the most consistent predictor
of the likelihood of death
in any given year is
the level of education.
And the close links of poverty
to health have been
known for centuries.
However, behavior patterns
-- diet, physical activity,
sexual activity,
addiction, and the like --
behavior is the single
greatest influence
over health in the
United States.
All told multiple studies using
different methodologies show
that the social determinants
shape about 85% of the health
of populations, with medical
care making up the other 15%.
Let me repeat that: Social
determinants shape 85%
of the health of populations,
with medical care
making up the other 15%.
Another way to look at this
is through a study released
by the Department of
Health and Human Services,
in which they estimate
that the 30 years
of increased life expectancy
attained in the 20th century,
only about five of those
years can be attributed
to better medical care.
The direct impact
of low literacy
on health outcomes is
broad and significant
for both children and adults.
The weight of evidence shows
that lower literacy is directly
correlated with greater number
of hospitalizations;
more outpatient visits;
less tight diabetes
control; more complications
from diabetes, including
blindness,
cardiovascular disease,
and neuropathy;
more emergency room visits; more
hospitalizations for asthma;
and I could go on and on.
Patients with lower literacy
are also much less likely
to participate in
screening and prevention.
These include childhood
immunizations,
smoking cessation
programs, Pap smears,
mammograms, colonoscopies.
The Center for Health Care
Strategies also indicates nearly
half of Americans have
difficulty understanding
and using health information.
This impedes their ability
to make appropriate health
decisions for themselves
and for their children.
An example of this is
one study in which 43%
of the participants were found
to have reading levels
below the sixth-grade level.
These patients were
3.4 times more likely
to not take their prescription
medications correctly.
Overall, people who read
at lower literacy levels
are three times more likely
to have adverse medical outcomes
than people who can read
at higher literacy levels.
There are very few high-quality
studies assessing a direct
impact of literacy
on costs related
to specific disease entities.
A problem is that the
confounding factors have been
very difficult to control.
But one study of non-pregnant
Medicaid recipients found
that those adult patients
with a reading level at
or below the third grade had
Medicaid charges over three
and a half times those
patients whose reading level was
above the third grade.
In aggregate, low literacy
is estimated to add
about $230 billion
to the country's
health-care costs each year.
I believe that the next great
leap in improving the health
of the nation will not
come out of the laboratory,
the operating room,
with new medication,
or with new processes,
but rather,
through systematically
addressing the social
determinants of health, or, to
use the current terminology,
moving health care upstream.
I also believe that the key
to enabling this leap is
improving the literacy rate
in the United States.
If you consider the direct
links of literacy or the lack
of literacy to education,
risky behaviors,
high-school dropout rates,
incarceration, and welfare,
it does not require any
suspension of belief
to understand that
literacy is the tool
to not just improve
overall health
but to break the
intergenerational cycle
of poverty and its
associated morbidities.
As I've touched on briefly,
literacy has profound effects
on medical care and the
social determinants of health.
Turning the question
around, can medical care
and health-care systems
affect literacy?
At Nemours, our core
operating principle is
that our responsibility
to children is more
than the diagnosis and
treatment of disease.
We believe that we
are shared guardians
of children's health and joy.
We believe reading and
literacy are essential
for both health and joy.
Nemours established our
BrightStart program in 2005,
which is aimed at
improving reading readiness.
We had the great fortune
to have Dr. Laura Bailet,
here with us tonight,
lead BrightStart.
In view of the tremendous
efforts by so many parties,
Laura believed that identifying
children at an early age
with reading vulnerabilities
would provide greater value,
giving a chance for intervention
before brain developmental
patterns are set.
We'll have a chance to hear more
from Dr. Bailet tomorrow, but,
in brief, she and her team
developed and validated the tool
for early screening, and
the screening has identified
that 20% or more
of prekindergarten children
have reading vulnerabilities.
The BrightStart team has
also developed a nine-
to 12-hour intervention
delivered over several weeks
that brings about two-thirds
of these children back
to the normal range.
And in hopes of enabling
universal screening,
the team has recently
refined and validated a tool
that can be used by parents.
In addition to our dedicated
reading readiness efforts,
we know that education and
literacy are negatively impacted
by chronic disease and
the absenteeism frequently
associated with it.
For that reason, we've piloted
a community health effort
for chronic disease
using asthma as a model.
We have involved
community health workers
as health navigators, community
liaisons as health integrators,
and these assess the patient's
home, provide ongoing education,
and connect the family
to community resources.
The community liaisons
also interface
and influence both governmental
and nongovernmental agencies,
such as housing, pest
control, transportation,
and health specialty resources.
Furthermore, with
parental permission,
we've piloted providing
school nurses full access
to the child's electronic
health record in order
to close any gaps in
communication or in hand offs.
Because of these efforts,
outcomes are better,
much better, and school
absences have decreased.
Nemours and health systems
nationwide are searching
to find concrete ways to improve
the health of populations.
This has become a primary
goal of health reform.
After generations of
treating patients one by one,
changing mind-set is
a very real obstacle.
Impacting the health
of populations requires
a deep understanding
of the social determinants
of health as well as working
with community resources
in new and unfamiliar ways.
It requires moving from a
command and control mode
to true collaboration.
For significant change,
it also requires a move
from a fee-for-service
model of reimbursement
to a value-based model of
care, where outcomes instead
of volume are reimbursed,
and those outcomes must include
some population health measures.
As a note, reimbursement
models are not unilaterally set
by health systems, and both
payers and providers need
to have the infrastructure
and systems in place
to successfully transition to
a new model of reimbursement.
And value-based health
care is 180 degrees apart
from fee-for-service-based
health care,
so it requires a
complete systems change.
Despite all the policy
discussions, money allocated,
and the multitude of programs,
both private and public,
the nation's literacy rate
has only slightly improved
over the last decade.
The responsibility for a child's
care, including literacy,
will always fall
principally to the parents.
It is they who, with
knowledge, understanding,
and the right tools, can do
the most for their child,
particularly in those critical
first 1000 days after birth,
when brain development is
rapid and the potential
for positive influence
is at its greatest.
The American Academy
of Pediatrics Books Build
Connections Literacy Toolkit is
a wonderful example of
empowering parents for success.
It also provides a clear
road map for early screening
and intervention
for care providers,
and it's a remarkable
illustration
of great collaboration and
alignment among organizations.
You'll likely hear more about
this from Dr. Hasinck [phonetic]
in her keynote address
tomorrow morning.
We in health care must pay a
larger and more proactive role
than we traditionally have.
For children, this means
aggressively addressing those
health determinants
that interfere
with skill acquisition,
both at a very early age
and during the school years.
We at Nemours believe
that child health
and reading skills
are closely linked
and that reading failure is
a major child health issue.
For that reason,
we will continue
to promote reading success
through innovative programs,
research, advocacy, and
partnerships focusing
on birth to age eight.
In conclusion, the challenge
for us all is how to intervene
in the lives of the
nation's children
so that their future
is one of choice rather
than being dictated
by circumstance.
Literacy is that enabled of
individual choice and it is
at the heart of it all.
When I reflect on
my personal story,
multiple adverse circumstances
were overcome by being lucky,
lucky enough to have a mother
who created an environment
conducive to reading.
With the expertise
and commitment of all
of you here tonight
and your colleagues
in the symposium tomorrow, the
fate of the next generation
of children and, thus,
of our nation's future
will not be left to chance.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Jane McAuliffe:
Dr. Bailey has agreed
to take a few questions,
so if there are.
>> David J. Bailey: Did
you see her twist my arm?
[laughter] Yeah, she's tough.
I'd be happy to take
any questions.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
I appreciate that.
Thank you.
Yes?
>> Thank you.
That was just, that was
one of the best speeches
on literacy I've ever heard,
so thank you very much.
[laughs] It felt to me
like, it really felt
like that was a call to action.
And I'm curious,
how, what are some
of the policy [inaudible] policy
things we need to do to take
that call to action
moving forward?
>> David J. Bailey: You know,
I think [inaudible
speaker] great question.
I wish I had all the answers.
I think that the, there's been
a tremendous amount of work
over the past ten years,
and it's accelerated
over the past five years.
You know, we now have a
national agenda around literacy.
Because there is a much more
dedicated approach to using data
in order to make decisions,
it gets people on board.
It gets people from both
political parties on board.
And the mayors of the nation
have actually been driving this
I think more than anyone else.
It really falls to
the local communities.
But when I think about
it, what can we do more?
And I think that, you know, you
have these two great efforts --
health care, which consumes
three trillion dollars a year,
and you have the
education budget,
and you have this
giant literacy effort.
In some ways, they're kind of in
silos, and, you know, certainly,
the literacy data and the
health data have both landed
on the social determinants
of health, that that is
where we can make a difference.
And I think even greater
emphasis on attempting
to intervene early in
that first 1000 days.
I think that is the
critical learning period
at which developmental pathways
can be positively altered,
and it requires far less
money and effort to do that.
So what does that mean?
I think we need to start
on the OB side, actually.
I think that with prenatal
visits, mothers need
to be informed how
critical reading, talking,
and singing are to
their newborn baby.
I don't know if to the fetus is
where we need to go, but maybe.
But beyond that, you know,
having literacy be a primary
point on which medical,
the entire medical team --
OB, pediatrics, family
practice -- gets on board.
You know, the American Academy
of Pediatrics has a
fabulous policy statement
and developed fabulous
materials.
A minority of pediatricians
actually do it.
And the reasons are
many, you know --
time, potentially reimbursement.
Other factors include
not knowing,
not being comfortable
with the tools.
Are the tools really validated?
And not being comfortable about,
are there folks in the community
who are, who can truly intervene
once we've identified potential
reading vulnerabilities?
I think the new tool kit
that the AAP has come
up with helps them
with that if, you know,
once it gets massively
distributed.
So I believe alignment,
not just within silos,
because I think the
literacy world seems
to be pretty well aligned,
but aligning the effort
with health care, with
policy, with education,
then I think we can
really make a difference.
For instance, with education,
it is very difficult to break
into the school system,
for someone in health care
to run a study longitudinally
over several grades
to understand
if an intervention's really
having a long-term effect.
And I think that if we can
find ways to break those silos
such that the large, different
pieces can then come together,
I think we'll make
much faster progress.
I think there's, you know,
in effect, there's a lot
of money out there, you know.
There's probably 30 to 40% of
health care is probably wasted.
You know, if we can reduce that
waste and apply it to this type
of effort into education,
I think over the long haul,
you'll see a healthier
population.
The problem is the will
to do it, you know.
It's difficult to make that
type of massive change.
But if we could just
gain some alignment
between all the different,
large constituencies,
I think we'd make
bigger progress.
Jane?
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> Jane McAuliffe: Looking
at it from another angle,
what are some of the signs that
you look for [inaudible] look
for in a three year old
that might alert you
to potential problems?
>> David J. Bailey: I think,
you know, well-child care tends
to focus, as it should, on all
of the developmental milestones.
You know, walking, talking,
when can they roll
over, and the like.
I think having a more
comprehensive or refined set
of tools that are
simple, easy to deliver
to evaluate a language and
a potential reading ability.
And, you know, the
physician doesn't need
to be the one doing it.
There could be community
resources that, you know,
could be, could come to the
office and be responsible
for that type of screening.
What would prevent that from
happening is the physician
believing that it's
reliable, you know,
that it's providing good data,
and having the ability to refer
to a, someone that is known
to intervene appropriately.
So I think a better,
a more refined,
more comprehensive
screening of speech, language,
and pre-reading abilities
would be,
would put us forward
a great deal.
Lauren [phonetic]?
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> Common risk factors
for [inaudible] disseminated
among health-care providers
and parents, early
childhood, day-care workers
and [inaudible] are
so important.
[inaudible] we know that,
in addition to the things
that Dr. Bailey talked
about, we know that--
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
We can argue whether that's
cause or correlational,
but not having them read
children's book [inaudible] is
highly associated with
delays in vocabulary,
which is then associated
with delays in--
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
Fallen from everyone's focus,
but that's a major health
risk factor for all kinds of--
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
We do know how to do this.
We know what the risk factors--
>> David J. Bailey: Right.
>> Are. It's partly a matter
of getting them out there
and having people, have that
shared [inaudible] that we all--
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> I guess as a [inaudible]
which is
where I find myself
most of the time,
I'm aware that finding the right
focus can be very difficult
because there are so many
different factors [inaudible].
And so my strategy is to try,
at the same time being aware
of all the risk factors,
to identify [inaudible].
Sometimes that's a lever
that allows us to move things
in the right direction
more effectively,
and it certainly leads to
a less hopeless outlook.
[inaudible] So I love the story
you told because the source
of resilience is so clearly
identified and the outcome was
so clearly [inaudible].
And my experience with
it in a clinic population
that is largely low
income, there's a lot
of [inaudible] that's in there.
I'm not saying that this is the
answer, but it's certainly part
of it that [inaudible]
we can bring to the--
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> Yeah. [laughs]
>> Well, the critical
dramatic turn of that story is
when they dig the foundation
[inaudible] town hall
in [inaudible], and they have
to do it in one day, right.
And a little boy comes in
and watches, and the comment
that he made: all of them
dug harder and faster when--
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
As a pediatrician, I think part
of my goal is to
[inaudible] right.
If I can notice a
parent who has that--
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> David J. Bailey: Yes?
>> I just have a question.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> David J. Bailey:
You know, there's,
there are several studies
that show that families
who were originally
middle class in terms
of socioeconomic status, but
through some traumatic event,
they are in poverty that, the
income has dropped so much,
and they live in poverty.
And even if they are able
to lift themselves up out
of poverty after 15
months, the one year spent
in poverty leads to, on average,
a delay in reading level that,
for a slight majority of those
children, they don't catch up,
even though the family is now
back into middle-class status.
And I don't know
if they don't catch
up because there's no
added intervention.
It's not recognized.
But relatively brief, if you can
call a year in poverty brief,
adverse circumstances, traumas
like that can have a
significant effect on literacy.
And so as a society and as
Robert mentioned, you know,
if a pediatric practice is
the primary medical home
for that child, the physician,
the caregiver, those people
in the office know
and understand
when those traumatic occurrences
happen and can then begin
to alert the family as to what
resources they may be able
to avail themselves in the
community in order to, you know,
prevent that reading
level being stunted
or perhaps intervening
to bring it back up.
I think it requires --
you know, that old cliche,
it requires a village -- it does
require all of the access points
at the children and
family to ensure
that that child reaches
their optimal development.
And so I think in terms
of pediatricians' offices,
that's a primary place, but it's
up to all of us in the community
in order to understand the
significant effect that traumas
or other delays can have
on reading level and, thus,
the future for that child and
even the future for society.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> And I just wondered
what you thought
about the potential
change in behavior
in those well-child visits.
And I know a lot of it
has to do with, you know,
the time that physicians are
allowed to have this visit,
but to really promote good
use of a book as a tool
to really determine a
child's [inaudible].
>> David J. Bailey:
Can you clone him?
>> Pardon me?
>> David J. Bailey:
Can you clone him?
[ Laughter ]
I think it's a wonderful idea.
I wouldn't have thought
of it myself,
but I think it is
a wonderful idea.
I think it may be very
difficult to change the behavior
of pediatricians who've
been out in practice,
and there are about
64,000 of them.
I think the chances
would be great, however,
if that were presented
as an option
or as an approach
during training programs,
that it would be
very easy to do that.
And I think that it would be, it
wouldn't take very long in order
to build a data set to show how
positive it is and, in fact,
how it may shorten the
time spent necessary
in a well-child exam.
So I think it's a fabulous idea.
Yes?
>> I'm Brian Gallagher
with Reach Out and Read,
and I have the pleasure
of working
with Dr. [inaudible]
and Dr. [inaudible].
And also, [inaudible], who
started at the Reach Out
and Reach program with Dr.
Atkinson [phonetic] many,
many years ago.
So two points.
One, to your point earlier about
[inaudible] with the policy.
We were thrilled to see that the
Every Student Succeeds Act bill
that was passed into
law and signed into law
in December does
include language
around literacy promotion--
>> David J. Bailey: Yes.
>> Starting in--
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
And to the point where residency
program too, we are seeing more
and more physicians come to
class with Reach Out and Read
to say, I was trained
in Reach Out and Read.
I got to my clinic.
There are no books.
Second thing I did was
[inaudible] was [inaudible] so--
>> David J. Bailey: Good.
>> It does take time to change
that culture and that behavior,
but we're starting
to slowly see it.
>> David J. Bailey: Good.
Thank you.
>> Jane McAuliffe: And I would
like to say we have folks here
from the Department
of Education,
Steven Hicks and [inaudible].
>> David J. Bailey: Hi.
>> Jane McAuliffe: So at least
we could have health care
and education be in the same
room [inaudible & laughter].
>> David J. Bailey: Well,
you've been very kind.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.